you under there
i'm vengeance
during opening weekend the batman took
in 250 million dollars worldwide the
film is already the biggest pandemic era
grocer for warner brothers and if you
need more of the cape crusader then you
need to visit the movie prop experience
located downtown inside the neonopolis
and here to show us more batman is
manager doug stewart it's good to see
you again buddy hey nice to see you
before we get started with this batman
stuff give everybody what's your
backstory in working in movies uh i've
been doing it for about 30 years most
recently i've been working in the
costumes making costumes
uh and one of them was or two of them
actually are two batman films not this
one but
uh batman and robin and we see right
here who's batman that's ben affleck
batman yes and that's uh i got in a
little trouble you got in trouble with
ben affleck on the set that was batman
vs superman yes it was wow we have a
story career that goes all the way back
to independence day and you've worked on
a couple of batman films and you brought
some really cool stuff to show us today
what do you have for us this stuff is
unreal well where do you want to start
why don't we start here with this right
here this is val kilmer's uh cowl from
batman forever and it's uh held up
pretty good that looks great yup can i
touch it sure this and you can see these
things down here at the the movie prop
experience this was actually worn in the
movie yes you didn't call it a mask what
do you call it cowl it's a cow yeah what
does that mean mask that means mask wow
that is so neat slide down here
this here is a robin's mask now here's a
mask
and this was worn by chris o'donnell
this was in the movie now something like
this you you with your job with the
movie you're putting it on him what are
you doing when you're working in the
movie i i i do a lot of different things
uh for example this was sculpted oh
let's keep it here somewhere everyone
can
this was sculpted and molded and then
cast into this urethane so it can be
used over and over and over again
um this here is a
aluminum batarang let's hold that up
from batman versus superman
and it's still kind of sharp and this is
what they call a hero prop
and can i say let me see hey i'm gonna
throw ted's on the other side of the
camera and i throw the right one
all right moving on here this here's
batman's gun that's uh batman versus
superman again it's a grapple gun
and a little bomb here
the bat that's shooting out of the gun
there this is something that he would
toss but these would these would fire
out and strings would be attached how
are you getting all of these things
that's up to our collectors hero prop
yes and they collect and accumulate
props from all over the place and
they've been doing it for
a decade or more the fact that this was
in the movie and i'm holding this right
now it's just it blows my mind i'm
holding this thing right now let's move
on here this is this is a very special
item right here uh heath ledger's script
from the dark knight
is the whole script right here the whole
script yeah and all these things you can
see down there at the shop and you guys
said you just got the edward scissor
hands this is we just installed those
today okay the last one here this is the
grand adam mall should i hold this up
this [ __ ] sure
this is a bat suit from batman forever
and it's made out of foam latex it's on
a
neoprene suit and everything's custom
made there's nothing here you could buy
in a store this is the real
zipper up top here are these bullet
holes what's the top now that the cape
would attach here okay and there's a
little little extra button that goes on
top of that you know how cool i feel
right now
i feel like can i can i hold it up she
gave me permission to hold up look at
this i'm back jason
this is such a need to hold up the belt
there too
now this stuff is really old so it's
kind of falling apart and what is this
made of this is foam latex this is a
urethane how do you guys get this but
val kilmer opts not to take this suit
home with him
uh well
ironically he probably has one
we made several of these for every
batman like this batman here he probably
has eight to ten suits that's what it's
used and uh have you seen the batman
movie i have and what are your thoughts
on it uh it's pretty cool you like it
yeah yeah i like every batman movie yeah
you got a personal connection to it yeah
i tried watching batman robin though and
that was a little campy and one of our
where's josh our photographer josh
you're around come on in here josh josh
is the biggest batman i know he's not
miked up here this is a special moment
when the biggest batman fans in the
world you're holding batman's suit this
is a very special moment imagine being
one of the world's biggest batman fans
and you're actually holding the suit on
camera put it up to your head right
there and give us your best batman into
my mic there
i'm batman
this is so neat okay we have to put it
back down we have to send it back to the
museum oh we got to send it back to the
museum we could put you on a payment
plan thank you
how much does a suit like this cost
i
it's almost priceless yes so it would
probably be as much as a lamborghini
whoa i'm saying you're tossing the thing
around like it's a toy from toys r us
doug thank you so much the movie prop
experience the website real quick uh
movieproperexperience.com
it's unbelievable the stuff you guys
have down there really appreciate it
thank you for sharing us these thanks
for having me this movie history right
here in front of us jillian i'll send it
over to you they